[SOUNDS OF ROOSTERS
AND LIVESTOCK]
Yvon, I'll meet
you on the path.
Keep a close eye on him.
ELISHA COOKE: You've
encountered Mr. Cross.
HAMISH GOAMES: I have.
ELISHA COOKE: Well?
What did he have
to say for himself?
HAMISH GOAMES: Riddles.
He's not the same man I knew.
Well that's a fortunate
outcome at least.
Not for my sister.
It's natural that a place like
this should transform a man.
I find myself anew in the silver
of the mirror every morning.
Now, I take it you spoke to
Captain Wale in Quebec City.
This is Mr. Charles Duquet.
You may speak freely
in front of him.
[horse whinnying]
[inaudible], good to meet you.
I did not come
here for tea, and I
prefer molasses, not honey.
Captain Wale did confirm
your ties to the company.
Well, you see, I am a
man who speaks plainly.
We found Lafarge's boy.
ELISHA COOKE: Now
that is a relief.
Well, it would be,
if he were still alive.
We found him dead, by the river.
A shame.
His mother will be
brought to her knees.
The boy's death
is on your ledger.
ELISHA COOKE: No, Mr. Goames.
You're mistaken.
I have orders
from Captain Wale
to form a partnership with you.
And though I find
it disagreeable,
I am a company man, and an
order is an order after all.
But I but a
simple barrel-maker.
My position within these walls
hinges on the good graces
of [inaudible].
You see my time in
the fiddle afforded
me some much needed reflection.
I am keeping my beard
low to the ground,
and as such, I would
point you in the direction
of a Mr. Bill Selby.
He's out there,
forming alliances.
Perhaps your Mr. Cross
knows of his whereabouts.
Good day.
I handled the boy.
And left the body for
only passing fool to find.
Better it look
like an accident.
It was an accident, Charles.
I see it in your eyes.
It was sloppy work.
I should dissolve
our partnership.
That would be an
unfortunate decision.
It's my decision to make!
Before you make
it, I would like
to know why you neglected
to tell the Hudson's
Bay men about the pistols.
What pistols are
you referring to?
If I were going to betray
you, I already would have.
When I found that
letter on your desk,
I gleamed a lot about your
arrangement to supply guns
to the Hudson's Bay Company.
But I must confess, I am still
curious on a couple of points.
It seems I misjudged you.
Where are the pistols?
I don't know.
They were to arm the
Iroquois so that they could
use them against the French.
I know not what they
were intended for.
I traded for them,
took my profit.
That's the end of the story.
Good, good.